mais oui vous êtes bien sûr 514 m ondes
moyennes ne vous étonnez pas si vous ne
recevez pas votre programme habituel
c'est aujourd'hui la générale de france
inter par et 514 m ce que sera france
inter paris 514 m eh bien
découvrez le en nous écoutant
une de toute façon je te signale qu'à 3
un certain 10 minutes après le démarrage
ensuite un avant l'arrivée au plateau de
gravelle et après la conférence de
presse
bonjour madame ici france inter parler
je voudrais savoir quelle est votre
réaction vis-à-vis des gens qui arrivent
avec des tapes paire de skis pour les
amener soit dans les gares soit même en
iran c'est des gars vous savez à tout
moment via une galerie sur la voiture ça
ne pose aucun problème
leur téléphone ou par lettre
les auditeurs peuvent nous poser toutes
les questions nous pouvons leur fournir
toutes les réponses
car nous sommes en liaison directe avec
les préfectures de paris du val de marne
de l'essonne des hauts-de-seine de la
seine-saint-denis et des yvelines en
liaison directe avec la préfecture de
police
la ratp et la sncf